when we begin this NewsHour with all the
latest developments from Niger where the
military Junta has now suspended the
Constitution and dissolved All State
institutions it comes hours after the
head of the presidential guard named
himself the leader of a transitional
Government after Wednesday's coup
abdrama tujiani made that announcement
on state-run television saying the
intervention was necessary to avoid the
demise of Niger tajani did not mention a
timeline for a return to civilian
leadership
[Music]
on Wednesday Security Forces gathered
within the National Council for the
Safeguard of the Homeland to put an end
to the regime of the seventh Republic
our action is motivated by the soul
desire to preserve our beloved Homeland
on the one hand in the face of our
deterioration of the security situation
of our country the president caused this
crisis with poor economic and social
governance
well the coup has triggered a wave of
both Regional and international
condemnation French president Emmanuel
macron says he would support sanctions
against niger's military leaders
first of all I'd like to make it
absolutely clear that France condemns in
the strongest possible terms this
military coup d'etat against the
courageous democratically elected leader
who's carrying out the reforms and
Investments his country needs and whom
we support as we did his predecessor
from the outset this kudata is totally
legitimate and deeply dangerous for the
people of Niger for Niger itself and for
the whole region let's bring in
ahmedress our correspondent who is
following developments for us from Abuja
in neighboring Nigeria Uma tell us a
little more about General ticiani
General chicheni General chiani has been
the head of the presidential guards for
a very long time he occupied that office
since 2015 when he was appointed by a
former president Mohammed yusufo who is
a close Ally the same person who he sort
of rejected when he tried to mediate to
end the crisis on the first day when the
coup was announced now Gianni has been
in charge of that the presidential
guards for a very long time eight years
now going to the ninth year and is
rumored to be one of the strongest
military personnel in the Nigerian Army
he hails from the library area and is
considered by most of his seniors and of
course colleagues as a very strict and
straightforward gentlemen however the
intervention his intervention into the
crisis underscores the division within
the Army first of all we've seen how the
rest of the army responded to the coup
the initial statement of the coup that
they want they will crush the Rebellion
unless the general Cheney and his men
gave themselves up and released
president Muhammad basil but eventually
that Army as we later learn uh sort of
fell in line and uh supported General
chiani it's not clear whether this will
continue because there are some
divisions within the Army in Nigeria
very interesting well we have also heard
multiple international calls for
president bazoom's release do we know
what's happened to him and his family
right now
foreign
still being held by the military
initially for the first two days we
understand that he's he was kept at the
presidential Palace but now with chiani
assuming the role of president or leader
of the country uh it's expected that
bazuma will be moved to another location
probably within a military Barracks why
he can be securely protected or rather
he'll be securely held in case
negotiations will follow later usually
when you look at coups in Africa West
Africa and the South especially in
recent times most of the leaders who are
deposed by the military were held as
bargaining chips we if you go by the
reaction of the International Community
International organizations like the
African Union Icarus the United States
the United Nations tough words from
these individuals tuffles from these
countries however uh what we really see
towards the end is a negotiated
settlement to extract the leader from
the hands of the military we've seen
that in Guinea we've seen that in Mali
and of course Burkina Faso a lot of
people believe that bazoom is being kept
as a bargaining chip very interesting
Ahmadi address there with all the latest
for us following this for us from Abuja
thank you Ahmed
well as Ahmed alluded to that Niger is
an important Ally of both the West as
well as being a hub for French military
operations in the Sahel the Border
region of Malia Burkina Faso and Niger
is largely controlled by armed groups
among them Al-Qaeda and isil
after Mali and Burkina Faso expelled
French forces from their territories
Niger then became the new focus of
Western forces France and the U.S have
air bases there and thousands of
soldiers in Niger Belgium Italy and
several other EU Nations as well as
Canada also have a military presence and
there are 200 police Personnel from
several EU countries well let's bring in
Daniel ezenger he's a research fellow at
the Africa Center for strategic studies
at the National Defense University he
joins us now from Washington D.C Daniel
what implications does this now have for
the foreign boots on the ground there
well I think it's an incredibly
complicated situation for all of niger's
foreign Partners anytime that you have a
a coup like this an unconstitutional
change in power it draws up all kinds of
legal problems for uh particularly
Western Security partners and that many
of them uh have laws on the books that
prevent them from working with military
governments and so given the degree of
security cooperation by uh France by the
United States and by other Regional
Partners all of that has been called
into question I think that it's also
incredibly important that those security
Partners continue to condemn this coup
as it is a very it's an unconstitutional
seizure of power it's illegal and uh and
so they need to stand by the commitments
that they've made to the uh the
popularly elected civilian president uh
Mohammed bazum still though Daniel there
are lots of vested interests as we were
just saying French operations for the
Sahel we've heard International
condemnation from Paris and from other
places too what is the strategy now I
mean the West has to decide between
working with the military in order to
try to maintain Security in that in that
region or pushing for bazoom to be
reinstated neither of them seem like
particularly good options
yes well I mean I think it's still a
very fluid situation you know there's a
an interest on the part of the Junta
that's taken power on the part of uh
General chiani uh to present it as
though they have broad widespread
support within the armed forces and that
they're in control of the situation and
certainly they have been able to control
the communication side of things these
last 36 hours or so but the truth is
that they really have relatively little
leverage right they are holding
president bazoom as your correspondent
mentioned earlier and he does present
something of a bargaining chip but
president bazoom has refused to resign
and really he shouldn't resign uh I
think that what we need to do what what
the Nigerian people need to look at now
uh are really what are their options for
resolving this constitutional crisis and
so long as the International Community
including niger's Regional Partners in
West Africa continue to deprive the
Junta of the recognition that it needs
it'll be unable to really govern into
the future uh Daniel I'm curious about
this because you're saying that the
military says or certainly wants to
portray that they are very much in
control that Niger is a huge country we
know there are enormous ways that are
unpoliced and there are so many
different armed actors here the coup
leaders have said that they're doing
this partly for security right what is
their plan
I it's not clear at all and it really
should be noted that while these coup
leaders are justifying their actions
based on security that actually in Niger
the security situation had been
relatively improving it doesn't mean
that there weren't security threats
there certainly are but if you look at
Niger in comparison to its neighbors
Mali and Burkina Faso two countries
where there is a military who to empower
Nigeria is doing much better in fact the
degree of violence in Niger compared to
Mali and Burkina Faso represents only
about 10 percent of the violent events
in the in the larger region and so
Nigeria really has performed a lot
better on the security side and so there
really isn't uh uh security
justification uh for this Junta just
like there isn't an economic one either
Niger had been improving uh its economic
situation largely over the last 10 years
under civilian Rule and so I it seems
much more likely that what's at play
here are egotistical Ambitions on the
part of a few officers within the Armed
Forces who have been able to figure out
a way to take control away and so I hope
that I hope that the the Regional
Community continues to deprive them of
that recognition that they need Daniel
if this is being driven by individual
personalities and Ambitions there are
obviously other powerful countries with
interests here Russia's Wagner Fighters
have been active in the region we know
might they now find a foothold with this
new leadership
uh you know I I can't speak to any clear
indications of that happening I mean
it's certainly the case that wherever
they have an opportunity or a window of
opportunity open that Wagner mercenaries
have been eager to try and expand their
influence in West Africa uh and they
have found ample opportunities in Mali
and Burkina Faso I suspect that we'll
see similar kinds of disinformation
campaigns in Niger now and it's
something that we need to be paying very
careful attention to we need the facts
from the ground as opposed to the the
rhetoric of anti-french imperialism and
Russia as some sort of security partner
and savior Russian mercenaries in Mali
have not acted in the interests of
Malian citizens they've acted as regime
security for the Junta and power there
in fact of all the events that Wagner
has been involved in in Mali it's
predominantly civilians four out of five
fatalities associated with Wagner
mercenaries are actually civilians that
have been killed not militant as
islamists and so hopefully Niger will
see the writing on the wall and
recognize that that is not a path that
leads to Greater security it's a path
that leads to Greater instability and a
worsening overall situation
their research fellow at the Africa
Center for strategic studies at the
National Defense University thanks so
much for joining us on Al Jazeera Daniel
really great to get your insights